it's great to be joined today by Jeremy
bamberg who's a professor of nanoscience
at the University of Cambridge also
author of the new book the secret life
of science Jeremy it's so great to talk
to you one place I want to start is one
that we've been discussing for a long
time and it relates to a talking point
that you sometimes hear thrown about in
popular culture that for some people
science is equivalent to a religion that
it works like a religion and one of the
most interesting things about science to
me that really differentiates it from
religion aside from all of the other
obvious ways is that rather than sort of
creating an echo chamber it actually
encourages the disproof of what are
often considered the sort of common
sense or accepted explanations for
phenomena in fact there's sort of like
great rewards for doing so and you
address that in the book but you also
point out that that sort of free-market
wild west element of science can really
narrow the focus of many scientists so
let's start maybe there talked a little
bit about how you believes the science
world is functioning in general at this
time okay it's a really interesting
question because it combines I guess two
aspects that scientists like one of them
is this sense of a mainstream something
that everybody agrees on that is very
robust I think that's what's one of the
amazing things about science that really
doesn't make it a religion that is
generally even though people might have
sometimes moderate results that might
even get published actually what happens
is this this huge amount of science
which is is building in different
directions is that it's like a soft
imagine like a big web of us a forest of
tree trunks enormous things and if you
add something that doesn't fit it just
gets papered over and lost and and
really the thing is incredibly robust
otherwise everything would come crashing
down at the same time as you say in this
sort of competitive system that we have
there are huge rewards for showing that
something is completely different so
trying to build a new branch in a
completely different direction instead
of an empty void that was never there
before and the the interesting thing is
how difficult it is to do that and you
to convince everybody because you start
growing a little sapling in some
particular area and if it really isn't
robust it just falls off it withers away
but that's how science sort of works is
that some of these ideas actually are
correct and then we build on them and
the whole enterprise incorporates that
into the fabric so I think that the
strong thing about a disease it evolves
it's not completely static it does
evolve and for that that you know this
this web of really strong results is one
of the strong things about science was
what's in good shape and yet at the same
time the competition encourages people
to find something different something
new that will gain them huge notoriety
and and therefore success but they have
to convince everybody else that that's
correct so um that the tension between
those sides is partly good what we might
ask is of the money of the huge amount
of resources we put into science are we
using it most efficiently to find those
new places yet that always seems to be I
mean here in the United States as I'm
sure you're aware there is a political
movement which likes to focus on such
financial subjects as waste and debt and
government spending and it's become very
very popular to find very particular
scientific projects that look at you
know the mating rituals of the manatee
only during April of odd numbered years
right I mean of course that's not a real
one but it's obviously it's always
caricatured right but my favorite
example is actually showing does
moonlight make plants grow very small
about these are presented as sort of
examples of where science is doing
something that's of no purpose or use or
significance whatsoever and I'm curious
what your sense is of when when that is
brought up does it make sense to argue
the merits of the particular scientific
endeavor or is there some broader meta
argument that is more logical in those
conversations I think the first thing
that's very important is that there is
lots of you
investment in science research and
science that just wouldn't happen
without our government's funding it and
it happened it's more and more the case
it used to be that we had big corporate
labs high tech I had enough funding to
actually go off and research things in
new directions and and because finance
is trying to be so efficient all of this
has gone so companies have almost zero
to really invest in in research a few
big giants are able to go in certain
areas and they make big noise about it I
used to work for Hitachi and that was
the same thing that had a large amount
of you know money and a small amount was
invested in really long range and
science projects which are impressive
but by and large it's only really
government funding that produces the
ideas that then can be taken forward
that for me is the thing to really
concentrate on now the difficulty is if
we knew how to choose which projects we
would you know work the good the good
ones then there would be no problem then
industry could just choose it if the
difficulty is when we do science we
really don't know how it's gonna pan out
there's a large amount of risk involved
so we have to fund in different
directions and the question is how do we
create a system which is most likely to
choose directions that will show these
new directions you know and unusual ones
as well as take the things that we want
to improve forward with a live highest
likelihood and because of the risky
nature of science that's a really
difficult thing met many scientists you
know many people will say oh we can pick
the winners but generally people can't
pick winners there's a large amount of
randomness involved so you know
scientists often complain that their
grant was not funded but it's actually
even more difficult to try and decide
from a huge array of grants which can
fund maybe a few percent of them which
ones are the best investment for our
society and generally scientists do
approach that in a you know in a very
impressive way but I actually in the end
is very difficult to do it and that's
why some of these other examples come
around where it doesn't sound like why
did somebody choose this sort of project
do you think that in some sense science
is expanding in a way that is not the
optimal way so one of the things that
surprised me in in this book I actually
started
but with no preconceptions at all I just
started to try and track down some
answers to the questions that I was
experiencing or people around me would
complain about this or that and I was
figured well it's your system you know
why don't you change it it's it's
nobody's making us do it this way and as
I started to try and understand it I
came across some things which were I
didn't expect to find them and I if it
turns out that most people don't know
about them
so one of the things that I think is is
quite important to realize is how the
number of scientist is increasing so if
I ask people you know is the number of
physicists in the world going up or the
number of chemists I mean most most I
just don't know certainly the general
public doesn't know but actually it's
increasing it at about 4% a year it's
about four times the world's population
increase so the world population is
increasing by less than a percent now
and dropping quite fast but the lot of
scientists has been carrying on at this
growth rate for over 50 years and shows
no signs of stopping at all and then
there's an interesting question what
what happens as you put more people into
science it just an it sounds like a good
idea most more scientists should give
you more science more breakthroughs and
more development it's not clear it works
like that
generally when you put more scientists
into science they don't do all radically
different things they tend to clump
around particular areas that are so hot
what we call bandwagon areas so they end
up sort of often replicating each
other's work or competing very intensely
but to try and do the same things and
that's part of this ecosystem is
competition that that is huge and
ferocious within science community so
the difficult thing I think is at some
point clearly they're going to be too
many scientists you know there probably
were too few scientists in the past but
the question is how do we decide what's
the right number of scientists we might
say well the free market will just
decide you know at a certain point our
societies will decide well that's the
number of scientists that we can fund we
don't just fund them in in you know
academia universities also industry
funds a huge number of scientists about
half the number in the world or a little
bit more or actually within industry and
so we're paying through them for them
through the products that we buy and
that might be you know medical advances
in a very large way these these are
these investment is coming from a whole
range of different directions but still
at the same time we're paying for them
so at some point we might say well you
know it'll just we'll just stop doing
that interestingly it seems for most
societies when the number of scientists
is a few percent he rises to a certain
amount of the GDP and it stops and I
always sort of joked that the reason it
stops is because if you if you write a
single page of what the country spends
its money on science funding stops when
it actually appears on that page because
it's got large enough it's something
like you know a fraction of the medical
budget a tenth or something like that
and it's because then people say well
what are we getting for our money and
it's very hard to decide because it's a
very long term investment those lines
Jeremy what I mean two things I'm
thinking of if I hear you saying this
are so you've got the increase in the
number of scientists of 4% which you
cited would your view of that be
different if number one funding for
science increased in parallel with the
increase in the number of scientists
because it seems if you increase the
number of scientists and not the funding
you're just taking the same amount of
funding and splitting it into smaller
and smaller pieces but also if there was
some mechanism to make sure that the
areas of focus are diversified rather
than this sort of clustering around the
same the same areas so both of these I
think are very important so scientists
themselves will tell you that it's
harder and harder to get funding and
there's some truth in it but of course
the budgets for science have always been
going up as far as I can see they've
never gone down they they are not I mean
they're generally keeping pace also with
a number of scientists but they don't
unequally spread what's happened is also
the aspiration of scientists to do more
more work has increased faster than the
rate of funding so and that's partly
because of globalization actually so
scientists used to work in a smaller
community maybe their national community
maybe even their smaller field and now
they see they're exposed to science from
all around the world and actually in the
media we want to see more more science
as well but more more interested in it
so scientists aspirations for what makes
great impact for breakthroughs has gone
up enormously so they want more
resources to do that
so partly it might be resetting
that'll deciding how we're going to do
that um the other side of it as you say
is how do we increase the diversity so
one of the things I think it's really a
you know a good way to look at science
is like an ecosystem like a natural
ecosystem one of the things we learn
from natural ecosystems is that if
everything is done the same way if there
is a dominance of a particular species
or a particular food chain in that
system
it loses resilience and its diversity is
contracting and it's a big problem for
that system in the long term one of the
things I now feel about the science
ecosystem is the globalization is not
wholly good because what happens is
people use more more best practice so
the way of funding science in the u.s.
is becoming more more likely where we
fund science in UK or the EU or in China
because people copy the same models and
so the same things get funded everywhere
to the same extent and the problem is
then a lack of diversity so some way to
reset that would be good so actually I I
joked also than the University I'm in
charge of creating anarchy so I think
Anik is extremely important or you might
call it diversity so different ways of
actually funding science so we just need
more more examples of this and thinking
of ways to enhance this change within
the system the book is fascinating it's
called the secret life of science we've
been speaking with the book's author
Jeremy Bamber who's professor of
nanoscience at the University of
Cambridge not Cambridge Massachusetts
three miles from our studio but
Cambridge England of course Jeremy thank
you so much for talking to me today
thank you very much right now